[MUSIC PLAYING]
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
Getting into data science
and machine learning
can be intimidating.
You have to label the
data, train your model,
see if it all works,
fine tune, and then
keep repeating those steps to
keep the model continuously
relevant.
That's a lot.
So today, I invited Carlos
Anchia, CEO of Plainsight,
a machine learning
and AI company
that makes Vision AI
accessible with no code.
Welcome, Carlos, and thanks
for joining me today.
CARLOS ANCHIA: Hi, Priyanka.
Thanks a lot.
It's always a pleasure
to join, and always
ready to talk and chat a
little bit about Plainsight
and how we can help everyone
better understand and utilize
AI solutions.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: OK, so
with that, what is Plainsight?
CARLOS ANCHIA: As a
company, Plainsight
aims to democratize
AI and enable
business users in
all sectors to build
complete and operationalized
vision AI solutions.
There are more than 3.2 billion
images and 720,000 hours
of video created every day.
This explosion of
visual data has
accelerated the growth and
adoption of computer vision.
It's a way for computers
to see more of the world
with an unblinking consistency
and a far greater accuracy.
The Plainsight
no-code AI platform
makes it easier and
faster to derive value
from highly accurate
and customized vision AI
solutions throughout an
organization or a business,
or business and enterprises
allowing automation,
predictions, and insight
into previously unseen data.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Well,
that is pretty powerful,
and it makes it really
easy for literally anyone
to use AI in their workflow.
But if I'm a user
of Plainsight-- now
let's say I have a
project where I'm
looking to use computer
vision, and I have some images
and I need to build a model.
What do I need to do?
CARLOS ANCHIA: So we
really take those images
and create a data
source for them,
and it's either images or video.
And that raw dataset
is where we now
need to collect it and
put it into the cloud.
At that point, we're
creating a version.
And we need to
provide some context
and create some sort of
labels around what you'd
like the machine to
learn from these images.
And to do that, we annotate
the video, or label the video,
with the specific
context that's required.
And that labeling is done
through our AI-assisted
features that we have
on the platform that
enable users to go much faster
through the labeling process.
You can imagine, a small
dataset doesn't take a long time
to go through.
But as the dataset
gets larger and larger,
these AI-assisted features
really help and decrease
the time it takes to
provide that sort of context
to the model.
Now that we have a model
that's ready for training,
we take that schema
or definition
of what we want to provide
the model during training
and build our custom container.
And we'll talk a little bit
about the custom container
in a bit, but this is
where we're actually
deploying within the
Vertex AI ecosystem
and selecting a framework for
how we want to train the model,
providing the images, and going
through the training cycle.
Once the training
is done, we need
to review the
accuracy to make sure
that we don't have loss, make
sure that we're identifying
items correctly,
and as part of that,
we've section the dataset
into a section for testing,
a section for validation, and
then a section for training.
And by identifying the accuracy
across these different segments
of your data, you can understand
how well the model performed
during the training cycle.
Once you've identified
that training is complete,
now we can deploy
the model and have
it served through Vertex
AI in a one-click deploy.
And this piece is where we're
now landing new predictions
on unseen data to understand
how the model is performing
in real-world conditions
and leveraging Vertex
AI as the underlying resource.
Once we understand how
the model is performing,
we can identify low
confidence predictions
and improve on the model,
augmenting the dataset.
And it's this
retraining that helps
us improve the model
over time so we have more
robust models in production.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: That
was an amazing demo.
Now my favorite
part of the show,
how does this actually work?
Now let's say I'm a customer
deploying the solution.
Take me behind the scenes
into the request flow
and the architecture.
CARLOS ANCHIA: Great.
This is also my favorite part.
So as a customer, we go to
Google Cloud Marketplace,
and we can enable our
Marketplace solution
with a one-click deploy.
Through some
configuration, we now
have the API platform
from Plainsight deployed
within a customer's network.
At this point, we deploy
a variety of containers,
but specifically, I want
to talk about the dashboard
and our API.
These are the entry points
into the application.
Business users will
consume the dashboard
in a no-code UI that
then consumes the API.
Everything is done through
the API, so as a developer,
you could access
just the API yourself
to enable all of these
different features
and functions of the platform.
These then are put
behind a load balancer
to make sure that we're able
to scale consumption of the API
as well as users that are using
the platform for labeling,
building models,
deploying services,
a variety of different
features and tasks.
Once we have the
dashboard stood up
and it's behind a
load balancer, we're
now starting to collect data.
And we talked about how
we have to get images
into the ecosystem.
And this is through
the ingestion pipeline.
We're adding images
into Google Cloud Bucket
or connecting up an existing
Google Cloud Storage location
into the application to leverage
our existing storage that we
have within the network.
This then allows us to have
a little bit of introspection
over the dataset.
We now get into this
piece around labeling.
And labeling is really
providing that context
that we talked about earlier,
but technically, it's
really associating a
relationship to an image.
So you have the
underlying resource,
where an image is
stored in a bucket,
but you also have to
store the type of label--
where it's at on
the image, what's
the resolution of the image.
These sort of
metadata and criteria
are the relationship data
that we store in Cloud SQL.
And again, this is all
within the ecosystem,
so the users and clients
have this available to them
within their network.
And then from the
Vertex API position,
we're really
leveraging Vertex AI
to help us with model training
as well as model serving.
These are the two
pieces, the core piece
of Vertex AI that are
leveraged by the Plainsight AI
platform that enable us to
have that templated container
and use those services
in a scaled fashion,
with the security provided
through the Google ecosystem.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: We'll
get into Vertex AI in just
a second, but I'm curious about
the memory store usage as well.
What are you using
memory store for?
CARLOS ANCHIA: So
memory store is really
around having access to files
and images in a fashion that's
cached throughout the ecosystem.
So memory store keeps our
images in a "hot" or ready state
and allows us to be
able to use those
through either the API or the
load balancer as we need them.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Wow.
Great, OK.
So coming back to Vertex AI--
we launched Vertex
AI at I/O this year.
And I've created a
series of videos on it,
so if you're interested
in checking them out,
they're linked below.
Carlos, I am really excited to
learn more about how Plainsight
is leveraging Vertex AI.
CARLOS ANCHIA: We're
very happy to be
using Vertex AI, specifically,
the pieces around training
and deployment, to
allow our platform
to leverage the underlying
infrastructure that's available
there in Google Cloud.
But really, we're deploying
custom containers.
And these custom containers are
templated from the Plainsight
perspective, so where we can
just update the model file
within the training container
and the same model file
within the serving
container to enable
a variety of
different use cases,
custom use cases, to be
deployed within the platform.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah,
I can't agree more.
Vertex AI custom containers
is such a great way
to templatize a
process like this,
and also to shield
away the complexity
from the external user.
Now what happens when a user
starts to build the model?
CARLOS ANCHIA: Through the
Plainsight no-code dashboard,
users are able to
add images and videos
from their own workstations
or connect up an existing GCS
folder location and use
that within their ecosystem.
At that point, we really need
to understand the relationship
between those images and
files that are being used
in the Plainsight platform.
And this is where
relational data is created.
Through this process
of identifying
the underlying
resource and providing
human-readable association for
that data, we relate the two.
And this is where
Cloud SQL really
comes in handy from a
managed services perspective,
because it's the same
in every deployment.
And now we have a
relationship in a matter
that the organization can
retain that data as well.
Remember, all of
this is really stored
in the customer's network.
Soon after the raw files
are added to the dataset,
users provide labeling of those
files within our ecosystem.
And this is that way for humans
to provide context to the model
during the labeling process.
Think of this part around
telling the computer what
you're really interested
in and discovering
in these new images.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah,
and in a realistic scenario,
this data is going
to continue to grow.
So how is the labeling handled
with the growing dataset?
CARLOS ANCHIA: Yeah,
great question.
And from your
experience and ours,
datasets always
continue to grow.
They never get smaller,
because you always
need representative data
for additional use cases
or environments that weren't
previously trained on.
And as these sets get
larger and larger,
it takes additional
resources to be
able to curate these
datasets properly.
So human annotation,
labeling workforces,
a collaborative environment
where people can work together
to be able to curate datasets,
to ensure that there's
quality within the dataset--
there's representation,
so we don't build
a bias in the dataset at all.
And this really leads
to a path of having
a more accurate dataset
that enables better
prediction, once we get into the
deployed instance of the model.
But from the
collaborative perspective,
once the labels have been
reviewed and approved,
this is where we
lock the dataset
and have our version control.
And this really is the way to
provide a point in time look
at the underlying data used
by the model in training
and in deployment.
It's a view into what's
called explainable AI, where
introspection into the model
and the dataset is possible,
so we can see how we're
representing the predictions,
whether we're overly biased for
one specific class, if we need
to add additional data,
or the underlying dataset
is biased in a given way.
We want our model to
perform in a robust manner,
and to do so the dataset really
has to be representative.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah,
and that representation
and explainable
AI and the ability
to do that is just so important.
And it's going to continue to
grow to have better models,
so having that is great.
And now we know that we have
the data that's ingested.
We have it labeled, so the
next step is training it.
How does training
work in Plainsight?
CARLOS ANCHIA: So with
the Plainsight platform,
training is a very
straightforward process
for the user.
It's a one-button
click that packages up
the location of the data
with its relational data
that we have.
It has our labels that
we've previously applied,
and it takes our
customized container
and deploys all of that
into a training environment
leveraged by Vertex AI.
And there, we can actually
perform the training
without having to
understand which framework
that we're going to use.
There's a lot of
sensible defaults
that can be made
for business users
to be able to succeed
in model training.
And this is really where
our smart ML feature
is leveraged to
its T, when we go
to deploy these no-code
model training cycles.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: And
that sticks out to me,
the no-code feature, the
one-click training the model.
And the user really does not
have to even know or define
the training process, which
is the containers that you're
deploying behind the scenes.
And you're just
leveraging Vertex AI
to do that in training.
But the user is shifted away
from that which is beautiful,
because they can just
focus on their data
and then making sure they get
an output, which is the model.
Now take me behind the scenes
of what happens when they
click on that Train button.
CARLOS ANCHIA: This
is a powerful feature
that we have around
the smart ML.
It's a way that
actually identifies
the appropriate framework
that's required,
because we have all the context
of what the user has been
telling us throughout
the whole process,
and kicks off the training
function for the user.
But it's not just being able
to take those logical defaults.
It's really about monitoring
the training while we're
training in Vertex
AI and identifying
when is enough to train.
Because training today is
a very iterative approach,
where we train for an hour
and see how it worked.
We train for five hours
and see how the model
worked during training.
But really, we can
budget an amount of time,
and then smart ML
will stop the training
when we have achieved a
productionalized accuracy
and a model performance
across the dataset
that we're training on.
And this is really
part of the features
where we're saving
additional costs
with underlying infrastructure
by not continuing to train past
when we need to, as
well as understanding
models and accuracy while
we are doing the training.
It saves a lot of time
to have introspection
within the training
prior to getting
into your serving
environment or when the model
is being used in production.
At this point, when the
model's ready to be deployed--
and smart ML will tell us
when the model's ready to be
deployed--
that model file is then added
into the Plainsight custom
serving container
that we deploy.
And this container is, again
with the one-button push
through our low-code
platform, this one-button push
enables that customized
container to be served
through Vertex AI's prediction.
And our prediction
container is a bit different
than the training container,
because the prediction
container, we're now interested
in unseen predictions
and want to understand what
the confidence score is
with that unseen prediction.
So this container
has integrations
that make it really
easy for organizations
to add those predictions
into a BI workflow
or an anomaly detection workflow
that's required in some cases,
where we're structuring the
data from video in a way where
it now can be consumed by
traditional models that
are non-computer vision models.
This prediction container is
enabled to do that by Pub/Sub.
Every prediction container
from our perspective,
when we deploy to
a custom container,
serves up a message
into the Pub/Sub,
where now a developer
or a BI integration
can now consume that message and
leverage that within a larger
ecosystem.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA:
That's amazing,
because once the
predictions are being made,
they're going to be made by
different applications, not
just one application.
So having that
connector with Pub/Sub
up as a messaging bus
in between is powerful,
because now any
number of applications
can just subscribe to that
model and get the predictions.
Now I see the benefit of
Marketplace deployment
here, because as a user, I
love that all the components
of this workflow are
deployed in my own project,
and I have access to it.
I can look at it.
Could you please
highlight why you
chose Google Cloud Marketplace
to be that delivery
mechanism for this service?
CARLOS ANCHIA: I
think, ahead of that,
it's important to understand
the choice for Google
as hosting provider for us
and why we chose Google.
Google is very forward
with their approach
to AI and their ability
to build features
that are enabling
these use cases
that we're talking about
in an innovative fashion.
And Marketplace was a
natural progression for us.
We wanted to be able
to meet the Google
customers in an environment
where they're currently hosted
and leverage their
entire ecosystem
through a very quick and
easy Marketplace deploy.
And as our customers
adopt vision AI solutions,
we want it to be able to
grow with them as well.
So we're leveraging the
customer's infrastructure
where security and
privacy have already
been built in their data
stores, where in a lot of cases,
customers don't want their data
to leave their environment,
especially for sensitive
information where there's
a lot of privacy concerns.
In these cases, we need
to meet the customer
in their data center or in
their cloud environment.
Additionally, we're
controlling egress costs.
We don't want to have to send
data out of the ecosystem,
because frankly, it costs
more to send it out.
If we can process it all
within the ecosystem,
we get to save on egress costs.
And by having all the data
stored within your ecosystem,
we do not create a vendor
lock-in environment
where customers
feel that they're
required to use Google
Cloud or Plainsight.
It's their data.
It's their private network.
And this is really
part of the key, where
we want to be able to
allow customers to innovate
in new ways for
vision AI solutions
within their environment.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: This
is so great to hear.
I can definitely see the
architecture, obviously
complicated, and I just
want to know what's
the secret of success here.
CARLOS ANCHIA: So the
secret to the success
here is really a collaboration.
And it's the [? do-it ?]
team [? Thomas ?] [? Bush, ?]
helping us form, how do we go
to market with this solution,
how do we leverage the best we
can the relationship that we
have to deploy from a
technical perspective,
and providing that guidance.
As well as the
Google Cloud team.
These guys have been rock stars
throughout the entire process.
And Kyle Grimsrud,
our account manager,
is the leader of the
rock band over there,
and he helps us navigate a lot
of the challenging situations
that we have.
And it's our own team.
Our internal teams really
work hard in making sure
that we enable the product
vision in our product
and have that user
experience that
is a delightful experience
that's easy and fast.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: Yeah,
like everybody always says,
it takes a village
to create anything,
and that's what you
just described there.
Awesome.
Well, congratulations
on that accomplishment.
Thank you, Carlos, for joining
us today, coming on the show,
and sharing what
Plainsight does.
CARLOS ANCHIA: Priyanka,
thanks a lot for your time.
And I appreciate
the opportunity,
being able to be a Google Cloud
Build partner and showcase
part of our solution
around vision AI
and how we're able to accelerate
innovation within enterprises.
PRIYANKA VERGADIA: All right,
so we learned a lot today
about a no-code
vision AI solution
that you can easily spin up by
a single click on Google Cloud
Marketplace, giving
you full control
over your data, resources,
and billing within your Google
Cloud project.
If you want to give it
a try or learn more,
check out the links below.
Want to see more real life
architectures like this?
Give us a like and
subscribe to get notified.